à droite du ciel il y avait les jbe et
la fusée jbe comme nos téléspectateurs
le savent
l'egypte y avait un petit chapeau sur la
tête et c'était là le secret de leur
intelligence quand un jbe réfléchissait
à quelque chose d'un peu compliqué hop
il mettait ça dans son chapeau sa passe
est automatiquement dans les autres
chapeaux et tous les gimmicks mettait à
réfléchir ensemble sans qu'on ait besoin
de leur explique pour la nourriture
il n'avait pas de problème non plus il y
avait des gibiers afin dé j bien laid et
des gibiers afro marges
c'est dire que pour aller sur une
planète même lointaine l'egypte y
n'avait pas besoin d'en porter autre
chose que leur chapeau et tout ce
monde-là voulait aller sur la terre
réussiront ils à partie
arriveront-ils même sur la terre que
sont ils devenus aujourd'hui